[موسيقى]
مساء الخير انا ميسون الواهد واقدم لكم
اخبار الساعه كالعاده نبدا بالعناوين
وثائق البنتاجون المسربه تفيد بوجود قوات
فرنسيه وامريكيه وبريطانيه في اوكرانيا
والجيش الفرنسي ينفي
ذ يحذر نتنياهو من ان حكومته ستدمر
اسرائيل ويطالبه بسحب صلاحيات
اسلحه ذكاء الاصطناعي الصينيه تقلق واشنطن
التي تعتبرها تهديدا للهيمنه الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
وفوضى مع صعوبه التفريق بين الحسابات
الموثوقه والمدفوعه مشاهير ومؤسسات كبيره
ترصد الدفع
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم خبايا جديده عن حاله الحرب في
اوكرانيا اضاءت عليها عشرات الوثائق
العسكريه السريه المسربه من البانتاجون
صحيفه بوليتيكو قالت ان الوثائق كشفت عن
وجود قوات من حلف الناتو باوكرانيا تتبع
لفرنسا وامريكا وبريطانيا
التسريب استدعى ردا سريعا من وزير القوات
المسلحه الفرنسي الذي نفى اي وجود لقواته
في اوكرانيا الوثائق المسربه اظهرت ايضا
مدى عمق اختراق الولايات المتحده للجيش
والاستخبارات الروسيه وفق صحيفه
الوثائق قد تم تقييما قاتما لقوه اله
الحرب الروسيه كما كشفت موادها ان الجيش
الاوكراني في حاله يرسى لها التقارير
الاستخباراتيه تظهر ان واشنطن تتجسس على
القاده العسكريين والسياسيين لاوكرانيا
فضلا عن حلفاء امريكيين مهمين اخرين وقد
ادت الوثائق المس ربه بالفعل الى تعقيد
العلاقات مع الدول الخليفه ما اثار الشكوك
حول قدره الولايات المتحده على الحفاظ على
اسرارها
وفي ملف الوثائق المسربه ايضا قال مسؤولون
في كوريا الجنوبيه ان سولا على علم
بالتقارير الاعلاميه المتعلقه بتسريب
العديد من الوثائق العسكريه الامريكيه
السريه وتعتزم مناقشه واشنطن في القضايا
التي اثرتها التسريبات وذلك بعد ان كشفت
الوثائق والتفاصيل حول مناقشات خاصه بين
كبار المسؤولين في كوريا الجنوبيه حول
الضغط الامريكي على بلادهم للمساعده في
امداد اوكرانيا بالاسلحه
التسريبات لم تستثني اسرائيل اذ تحتوي
الوثائق على معلومات تفيد بتشييع الموساد
الاسرائيلي لموظفيه والمواطنين
الاسرائيليين على الاحتجاج ضد الحكومه وفق
الصحيفه نيورك تايمز في المقابل جاء الرد
الاسرائيلي بالنفي اذا اعلن مكتب رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي نتنياهو ان القصه التي
اوردتها نيويورك تايمز واشنطن بوست كاذبه
ولا اساس لها على الاطلاق بحسب ما نقلت
وسائل اعلام محليه
من موسكو تنضم الي الباحثه في العلاقات
الدوليه في مدرسه الاقتصاد العليا لانا
بادفان صيدلانه اهلا بك معنا كيف ستتعامل
روسيا مع هذه التسريبات وخاصه بانه معظم
هذه التسريبات تتحدث عن الحرب في اوكرانيا
تتحدث بان الجيش الروسي يعني يواجه مشاكل
كبيره في معاركه وخاصه في
يعني بدايه هناك ضبابيه كبيره وشكوك حول
هذه الوثائق ومدى مصداقيتها اولا تم اتهام
ان روسيا هي التي تعمل على تسريب هذه
الوثائق ولكن من غير المنطقي ان تسرب
روسيا المعلومات التي وصلت اليها وخاصه ان
جزء من هذه المعلومات تخص الاراضي
الاوكرانيه وايضا الجيش الروسي المتواجد
على تلك الاراضي ثاني يوم النقطه المهمه
جدا بين غالبيه المعلومات التي سربت يعني
الجميع يعلم بها وهي ان حلف الناتو هو
مشترك في مع الجيش الاوكراني ويعمل دعم
الجيش الاوكراني وان هناك فعليه
موقف روسيا اذا تم التاكيد بان هناك قوات
لحلفاء اوكرانيا لقوات النيتو كالولايات
المتحده فرنسا وبريطانيا متواجدين على ارض
اوكرانيا
يعني سابقا في مجلس الامن تمت روسيا تلك
الدول باشراك نفسها بحرب مباشره ضد الجيش
الروسي المتواجد على الاراضي الاوكرانيه
بالتالي كل هذه المعلومات على الجانب
الروسي يعلمها بشكل كامل وبالتفصيل وخاصه
ايضا المعلومات التي سربت بالوثيقه عن
تدريب الجيش الاوكراني عن دعم جيش
الاوكراني باسلحه متطوره واستراتيجيه
الجميع يعلم بها ولكن تكمن الخطوره ليس
فقط للجانب الروسي بقدر ماء الجان الدول
التي سربت معلومات عنها مثل اسرائيل مثل
كوريا الجنوبيه وفرنسا وبريطانيا كل دوله
الان تنكر مصداقيه هذه المعلومات وخاصه ان
من شرب من شربت من قبل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه التي تصنف نفسها على انها العين
الخامسه لسريه المعلوماتنا مع الدول التي
تجمعهم مثل كندا نيوزيلندا استراليا
بالتالي هذه المعلومات التي سربت ليس
بالخطر على الجانب الروسي بقدر ما هو خطر
على الدول التي سربت معلومات ولكن هناك
ايضا من هذه في هذه التسريبات يتم الحديث
عن اختراق كبير للاستخبارات الامريكيه
للجيش الروسي
نعم ايضا كان هناك معلومات في الاشهر
السته السابقه عن اختراقات كبيره للتقودها
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه للاجهزه
العسكريه الروسيه وخاصه قبل يعني في بدايه
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه قد سربت واشنطن
ايضا معلومات تفيد بان هناك حشد كبير
للجيش الروسي على مقربه الاراضي
الاوكرانيه وبان روسيا تريد تشن عمليه
عسكريه ضد الاقاليم الاربعه بالتالي
المعلومات التي سربت ايضا من قبل واشنطن
سابقا تفيد بان لربما فعليه ان هذه عمليه
تسريب ربما تكون ايضا واشنطن تريد تسريبها
بهدف تشكيك وارباك الجانب والاجهزه
المخابرات الروسيه بالتالي لا يمكن تصديق
مصداقيه هذه الوثائق وانها فعلا هي مسربه
او انها فعليا يعني عمليه
استخباراتيه جديده تقودها الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه هدفها ايرباك الجانب
الروسي واتهام روسيا والصين بانها تعملان
على تجسس على القوات والمعلومات والبانت
الامريكي
بالتالي هناك عمليه ضبابيه حول هذه
الوثائق التي سربت وعن مدى مصداقيه فعليه
انها شربت او ان عمليه امريكيه هدفها
ارباك الجانب الروسي وخاصه ان نحن في فصل
الربيع الفصل الذي تحدث عنه كلا الجانبين
الجانب الروسي والجانب الغربي وخاصه في
منطقه بخموت بالتالي ربما هو عمليه انسحاب
امريكي من دعم الجيش الاوكراني الذي كان
له تطلعات اعاده تشبه جزيره القرم شكرا لك
من موسكو الباحثه في العلاقات الدوليه في
مدرسه الاقتصاد العليا لانا بادفانا
[موسيقى]
الوثائق المسربه من البانتاجون تكشف
معطيات صادمه
امريكي كبير في الجهاز العسكري الروسي
والاوكراني
[موسيقى]
الوثائق اظهرت قدره واشنطن على تحذير
اوكرانيا بشان الضربات المخطط لها من
روسيا وتقييم اله الحرب الروسيه
الوثائق ترسم صوره للجيش الروسي المتهاوي
الذي يكافح في حرب اوكرانيا
وتكشف نقل المعلومات الحساسه الكياف
للدفاع عن نفسها من خلال تحديد توقيت
الضربات واهدافها
الوثائق تظهر ان عملاء واشنطن يخترقون
تقريبا كل الاجهزه الامنيه الروسيه
مسؤول استخباراتي غربي قال ان التسريب
مؤلم وقد يحد من تبادل المعلومات
الاستخباراتيه
[موسيقى]
الخصومه في الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه تخطت
اللاعبين الرئيسيين وبات كل طرف يحارب على
جبهات متعدده ليس عسكريا بالضروره تقرير
لصحيفه واشنطن بوست كشف ان اوكرانيا تقوم
بتعزيز دفاعاتها على حدودها مع بيلاروسيا
عبر زرعها الاف الالغام للدقه اكثر
اوكرانيا زرعت اكثر من 6000 لغه مضاد
للدبابات على طول حدودها مع بيلاروسيا
وروسيا لتحصين دفاعاتها في المقابل موسكو
منشغله بالعمل على مواجهه الهجمات
الاوكرانيه المحتمله في الاسابيع المقبله
حيث يكثف الروس خطوط تحصيناتهم على الجبهه
وفي شبه جزيره القرم لمنع اختراق قوات كاف
وفق صحيفه الغموض الفرنسيه لانه اذا تمكنت
اوكرانيا من اختراق هذه الخطوط سيكون احد
العوامل الحاسمه في نجاح او فشل الهجوم
المضاد الاوكراني المعلن في الربيع
منذ بدايه الحرف في اوكرانيا اذرع
الروبوتات والات تصنيع الاسلحه لم تعرف
الكلله في مصانع الذخيل الاوروبيه والهدف
انتاجوا قذائف مدفعيه من عيار 155 ملم
اوكرانيا بامس الحاجه اليها في ميدان
الحرب تقرير لصحيفه نيور الامريكيه كشف ان
شركه نامو ستنتج ما يصل الى 200 الف قذيفه
سنويا بحلول عام 2028 اذا سارت الامور كما
هو مخطط لها لكن مشاهدينا هذه الكميه لن
تكون كافيه ولن تاتي قريبا والسبب ان
القوات الاوكرانيه بحاجه الى 250 الف
قذيفه 155 ملم كل شهر لصد تقدم روسيا
وبهذا سيظل الانتاج اقل بكثير من تلبيه
احتياجات اوكرانيا اصداء هذه المشكله
ترددت في المجالس الاوروبيه ويتساءل
محللون عما اذا كانت اوروبا ستكون قادره
على توسيع الانتاج من قط اعها الصناعي
العسكري بما يكفي لتزويد اوكرانيا
بالمساعده التي تحتاجها لكن يبدو ان
الجواب لا على الاقل في المدى القصير حيث
يامل حلفاء الناتو بحسب الصحيفه بتلبيه
الاحتياجات الفوريه لاوكرانيا من
المخزونات في الداخل والخارج في الوقت
الحالي
الامال التي عقدتها القوات الاوكرانيه على
الطائرات 29 سلوفاكيا لتعزيز دفاعاتها
الجويه قد تتبدد لماذا لان وزير الدفاع
سلوفاكي اعلن ان الطائرات المقاتله التي
تم تسليمها لاوكرانيا هي معيبه فهي قادره
على الطيران لكنها عاجزه عن تنفيذ مهام
قتاليه وفق تعبيره فبحسب صحيفه ديل
التليجراف الاجزاء المعطله الوحيده في
الطائرات الحربيه جمعها التقنيون روس
عملوا في قاعده القوات الجويه سلوفاكيا
حتى العام الماضي فبموجب اتفاق طويل الامد
مع روسيا تمركز الفنيون الروس في سلوفاكيا
لامتلاكه المعرفه اكبر بالطائره السوفيتيه
مقاتله مايك 29 هي طائره اسرع من الصوت
وهي من الجيل الرابع قدرتها مذهله على
المناوره والوصول للاهداف واطلاق الصواريخ
من مسافات بعيده كفاءه هذه الطائره في
المعارك تعتمد على العوامل اولها العدد
لما في ذلك من اثر وفعاليه اما العمل
الاخر فيعتمد على خبره اوكرانيا في
استخدامها وتوفير قطع غيار يمكن استخدامها
[موسيقى]
في اخبار الساعه بعد لحظات نتابع مجلس
النواب يستدعي رؤساء بنوك وشركات للتحقيق
بسجلات ماليه تخص عائله بايدن
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد مع تواصل صراع النفود
بين واشنطن كشف التقارير غربيه عن مخاوف
بلد الاداره الامريكيه من اسلحه الذكاء
الاصطناعي الصينيه وسط التحضيرات من دخول
هذه التقنيه سباق التسلح بين الطرفين
نتابع
تحديات كثيره فرضتها اسلحه الذكاء
الاصطناعي بين الصين والولايات المتحده
والتي تنذر بمنافسه شرسه عنوانها الصداره
للاذكى الصناعيه فمع دخولي هذه الاسلحه في
سباق التسلح بين بكين و واشنطن والذي احدث
نقله نوعيه في الاستراتيجيه الحربيه
الصينيه على المستوى التكتيكي والعسكري
كشف تقرير صادر عن صحيفه الجارديان عن قلق
امريكي من ان تستخدم بكين هذه التقنيه في
السعي وراء السلطه لتحل محل الولايات
المتحده باعتبارها القوه العظمى للذكاء
الاصطناعي في العالم من خلال اسلحه تقنيه
يمكن الاعتماد عليها في الحروب المستقبليه
فالجيش الصيني يسعى لتعميم مفاهيم حرب
الالات الذكيه او حرب الروبوتات المقاتله
المؤهله لتنفيذ العديد من العمليات
العسكريه من خلال روبوتات ومعد صغيره
مجهزه بمدافع رشاشه ونظم رؤيه ليليه
وصواريخها واجهزه استشعار للقيام بالعديد
من المهمات في الخطوط الاماميه وفقا لمعظم
المقاييس التي تعتمد عليها مؤسسه السياسه
الخارجيه في واشنطن فان احتمال وصول الصين
الى الذكاء الاصطناعي العام قبل الولايات
المتحده يبدو وكانه تهديد وجودي للهيمنه
الامريكيه فالتحركات الصين التي تسعى
لتكون مركزا للابتكار في مجال اسلحه
الذكاء الاصطناعي بحلول 2030 يمكن ان تؤدي
الى سباق تسلح جديد تغذيه الاجيال القديمه
من التكنولوجيا وسط مخاوف تتعلق بالخيارات
السريعه التي تتخذها الاسلحه الذكيه من
دون تدخل بشري
سياسي ساده اجواء مضيق تايوان في ظل
المناورات التي تنفذها الصين لليوم الثاني
على التوالي مصدر مطلع اكد بان نحو 20
سفينه عسكريه منها نحو 10 سفن صينيه وعشر
سفن تايوانيه تتواجد وجها لوجه بالقرب من
الخط الاوسط للمضيق واضاف المصدر نصين
اجرت محاكاه لشنه هجمات على اهداف عسكريه
اجنبيه قباله الساحل الجنوبي الغربي
لتايوان وفق ما نقلت رويترز فيما اعلنت
وزاره الدفاع في تايوان انها رصدت احدى
عشره سفينه حربيه صينيه
وسبعين طائره في محيط الجزيره
[موسيقى]
المستوطنين اليوم باحات المسجد الاقصى وسط
حمايه من القوات الاسرائيليه التي قيدت
وصول المصلين المسلمين الى المسجد نحو الف
من المستوطنين اقتحموا المسجد وذلك بعدما
اقتحمت الشرطه المسجد واخرجت المعتكفين من
داخله بالقوه لتامين وصول المستوطنين الى
المكان الشرطه الاسرائيليه اوسط امس بعدم
السماح الى المستوطنين باقتحام المسجد
الاقصى خلال العشر الاواخر من شهر رمضان
في محاوله لتجنب زياده التوتر
اما زعيم المعارضه الاسرائيليه يا
ايرلافيت طلب رئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نتانياهو بمصادره الصلاحيات المتعلقه
بالحرم القدسي من ايتامار بن جير واكد
لافيد عقب لقاء جمعه بنيتانياهو انه يدعم
اي اجراء امني تقدم عليه اسرائيل ردا على
الهجوم الصاروخيه الاخيره وفي وقت لاحق
اكد حزب الايكود ان لافيد اختار ممارسه
تافهه في الوقت الذي تحارب فيه اسرائيل
على ثلاث جبهات
[موسيقى]
الى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وفي ملف
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب وما
يخص ملفه القضائي تحديدا تحقيقا جنائيا
شرفا على الانتهاء الاتهامات فيهما ليست
فقط ضد ترامب ولكن ربما ضد عشرات او اكثر
من حلفائه وفق صحيفه نيويورك تايمز
التحقيق الاول يتعلق بجهود قام بها ترامب
لقلب نتائج انتخابات 2020 في ولايه جورجيا
اما الثانيه يتعلق بهجوم السادس من يناير
على مبنى الكابتن مايكل تهن المحامي
الشخصي السابق لترامب اكد ان توجيه
الاتهام الى الرئيس السابق يخدم العداله
والمساءله لكنه فظيع بالنسبه للولايات
المتحده على حد تعبيره
[موسيقى]
يعمل على استدعاء رؤساء وبنوك وشركات
للتحقيق بسجلات ماليه تخص هانتر بايدن
نجلاء الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن واشارت
فوكس نيوز الى ان التحقيقات التي ستجريها
لجنه الرقابه في مجلس النواب ستركز على
سجلات مجلى بايدن الماليه
قال المدعي العام السابق ويليام باري ان
دونالد ترامب حفر لنفسه فجوه فيما يتعلق
بمجموعه القضايا القانونيه التي يواجهها
في اشاره الى انه يتجه الى الانتخابات
المقبله باعتباره اضعف المرشحين
الجمهوريين في السباق الانتخابي
قراءتي كانت انهم سيوجهون الاتهام للترامب
ومازلت اعتقد ان هناك فرصه جيده لذلك كل
ذلك يعتمد على مدى حساسيه المستندات
المقدمه وايضا الدليل الذي لديهم ضد ترامب
بخصوص الكذب واعطاء معلومات خاطئه لنقلها
الى الحكومه ترامب لديه ميل للانخراط في
سلوك متهور ومدمر للذات وهو ما يعرضه
للمتاعب في كثير من الاحيان لا اعتقد ان
نفس الامر ينطبق على حاله براج ولكن
بالتاكيد لقد حفر لنفسه ثغره في المستندات
واحداث من يناير لذلك لا يفاجئني ان لديه
كل هذه المشاكل القانونيه لقد تم تحضيره
من ذلك قبل مغادره منصبه
في اخبار الساعه سنتابع بعد قليل افكار
جديده وطرح مختلف تقدمه الاعمال الخليجيه
في رمضان 20 23
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد وصل وفداني سعودي وعماني
الى صنعاء لبحث جهود احلال السلام وتراس
الوفد السعودي السفير محمد الجابر الذي
التقى صحبه الرئيس الوفد العماني القيادي
الحوتي مهدي المشاط اللقاء سيبحث تمديد
الهدنه والعمل على اجراءات لبناء الثقه
واختبار التوصل الى حل سياسي شامل في
اليمن
يشهد المسجد الحرام في مكه المكرمه اكثر
من 77 لوحه ارشاديه موزعه في داخل الحرم
وساحته يستفيد منها الالاف من المعتمرين
والزوار من مختلف الجنسيات وتعمل هذه
اللوحات الارشاديه الالكترونيه على ارشاد
المستفيدين من الزوار والمعتمرين على مدار
الساعه ضمن الخدمات المقدمه لتسهيل وتيسير
اداء العمره والصلوات
من مكه المكرمه ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه
اسامه قاسم اسامه مساء الخير ابرز
التجهيزات
للعشره الاواخر من رمضان المبارك
اهلا ميسون تحيه طيبه لك ولجميع مشاهدينا
العربية نقول لكم الصوت والصوره اليوم من
مطافي الدوري الاول هنا في المسجد الحرام
طبعا نحن الان دخلنا من باب الملك عبد
العزيز احد اكبر ابواب المسجد الحرام الذي
يؤدي الى صحن المطاف بعدما شاهدنا ايضا
جهود وزاره الحج والعمره في التاكد من
تصاريح الزوار والمعتمرين في دخولهم الى
صحن المطار كما اسبقنا هذه الشاشات التي
نتحدث عنها اليوم هي شاشات ارشاديه توعويه
للزوار والمعتمرين بعده لغات تؤدي ايضا
الى وصف الاماكن التي يريدونها سواء
المطاف او المسعى او ادوار
المطاف او حتى المداخل والمخارج وبحديثنا
اليوم عن الخطه التشغيليه وخطط التجهيز
العشر الاواخر نتحدث عن الخطه التنظيميه
للحد من الازدحام وما هي الجهات المسانده
والوكالات التي تعمل على مدار الساعه
لخدمه الزوار والمعتمرين بالتاكيد انه
وزاره الحج والعمره اهتمت
كميه اصدار التصاريح للزوار والمعتمرين
والتاكد من وقت ودخول الزائر والمعتمر الى
المسجد الحرام للحج من الازدحام وايضا
دعوتهم للابتعاد عن مواطن الزحام طبعا
ايضا اوصت الوزاره والجهات الاخرى ضيوف
الرحمن بتجنب الصلاه في الممرات وفي
المداخل والمخارج او الصلاه في مسار
العربات وذلك حفظا للنظام وحرصا ايضا على
الخشوع نتكلم اليوم ايضا عن تجاوز عدد
المعتمرين المصلين حوالي تقريبا 17 مليون
زائر ومعتمر الى هذه اللحظه وتوقعات بين
تزيد هذه الاعداد في العشر الاواخر نحن
اليوم نشهد ايضا استمرار الخطه التشغيليه
الثانيه ما زلنا نشهد الى الان نجاحها بعد
النجاح الخطه التشغيليه الاولى في العشر
الاولى من شهر رمضان المبارك وايضا نحن
نستعد للدخول في الخطه التشغيليه الثالثه
وهي الخطه التشغيليه الخاصه بالعشر
الاواخر بالتاكيد العشر الاواخر كل الجهات
الموجوده هنا سواء الرئاسه شؤون الحرمين
او الجهات الامنيه او حتى الجهات الطبيه
والتي تقدم الخدمات الانسانيه علاجيه على
هبه الاستعداد لاستقبال الاعداد الكبيره
من الزوار والمعتمرين خلال هذه الفتره
نتحدث اليوم ايضا عن الخدمات التي تقدم
لهم وستقدم بشكل مكثف ايضا في الايام
القادمه وبالتحديد كما اسبقنا في العشر
الاواخر عن سقيا زمزم وصل اليوم عدد
النترات التي قدمت للزوار المعتمرين حوالي
25 مليون لتر من سقيا زمزم ايضا الخدمات
الاخرى كخدمه العربات التي نشاهدها الان
وايضا خدمه الدخول الى المساحات وتوفير
مداخل ومخارج للزوار والمعتمرين نتحدث
اليوم ايضا ميسون عن ما هي هذه الخدمات
التي تاتي بشكل مباشر على مدار الساعه على
مدار 24 ساعه ولا تتاثر باعداد الزوار
والمعتمرين بل بالعكس من ذلك تماما تاتي
هذه الخدمات وكان الاعداد على ما هي علينا
تحدث اليوم نتحدث اليوم ايضا عن هذه
الصوره التي تشاهدون الان في دخول الزوار
والمعتمرين الى صحن المطاف من المدخل باب
الملك عبد العزيز وهو البوابه الاكبر كما
اسبقنا للدخول الى صحن المطاف كل هذه منذ
اليوم الاول اسامه والعمليه
واضحه اشكرك ودائما سنكون معك كنت معي من
مكه المكرمه مراسل العربيه اسامه قاسم
الاعمال الخليجيه في شهر رمضان هذا العام
نفست بقوه وحققت نجاحا مهما حيث ظهرت
افكار مختلفه تم طرح قصص جديده دارت في
جغرافيا الخليج او حتى خارج الخليج مقدمه
حكايات ملفته تستحق التوقف عندها
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
سيارتي الروز والله ما تردها والله
مرحبا لم يكن مسلسل طاش ما طاش جماهيريه
مطالب بالعوده بالجديد الجمهور كان مكتفي
مبدئيا بفكره عوده ثنائيه ناصر القصبي
وعبد الله السدحان للعمل ليس ذلك وحسب
والعوده بعد النجوم ممن كانوا مبتعدين
خاصه يوسف الجراح وفهد الحيان
الا انه كان ينتظر ان يعود العمل بقصص
وحكايه وقضايا تشبه ما يعيش اليوم وواقع
مختلف تماما بالطبع عن الماضي وهو ما كان
فريق العمل ليحرص عليه طوال فتره التحذير
يعني هذا اكثر شيء يشغلنا انك انت شلون
شلون ترجع الجو
العام حق
طاش شخصيات بافكار البسيطه هذا اكثر شيء
كان شاغلنا
يعني واتوقع ان حنا يعني
لمسنا هذا الجو يعني
رحنا الجو
خفيف
حاولنا نركز على الجو الشعبي
العديد من النجوم يا شباب البارزين على
الساحه الان بينما ذهب الى مواقع تصوير في
كل ارجاء الرياض وهو امر اسعد الجمهور جدا
الذي يتابع بحب واهتمام وينتظر المزيد انا
سعدت بكثير من الحلقات اللي قدمناها نعم
احنا قعدنا واخذنا واعطيناه في ورشه النص
انا سعيد بالشخصيات اللي قدمتها وكذلك
سعيد بالشخصيات اللي قدمها ناصر والزملاء
اللي شاركونا هذا
العمل هذا عمل سهل سهل صعب ماني عارف ابوه
قلت اقول انا كاني في حلم
صدقا كاني في حلم انا المكتوب على الورق
صعب
والحمد لله تيسر
بنسبه مشاهده عاليه اردنا ان نعرف لماذا
تم الناس بالعمل لهذه الدرجه وما رايهم
بالجزء الجديد منه فنزلنا اليهم وسالناهم
عوده لهم نصر القصوي وعبد الله السدحان
ويعني احنا كنا مشتاقين لهم وبعد غياب
طويل بصراحه عوده جدا جدا جميله اسعدت
اتوقع مو بس الشعب السعودي الخليج كامل
هذولي يعني
جيل الطيبين وذكريات مره حلوه قديمه
وتجددوا لنا الذكرة الثنائيه كبيره تربينا
عليهم ونحن صغار
وشفنا بدايتهم كانت قويه السنه هذه
ونتمنى ان شاء الله يمتعونا في الحلقات
القادمه
يريد
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وما زال الجدل حول ايلون ماسك وتعطيه مع
تويتر تطبيق منصه التواصل الاجتماعي تويتر
لقرارها بازاله علامه توثيق عن كل حساب
يرفض الدفع احدث فوضى كبيره اثبات يصعب
التفريق بين الحسابات القديمه الموثقه
لشخصيات عامه مثل براك اوباما وحسابات
التوثيق المدفوع شهريا وبالتالي قلل
القرار من قيمه تلك العلامه وفقا لخبراء
بمنصات التواصل الاجتماعي بالمقابل اعلن
الكثير من الشخصيات الشهيره ومنهم نجموا
كره السله
الامريكيينس وصحيفه نيورك تايمز انهم لن
يدفعوا اشتراكا مقابل تحويل علامه الطائر
على صفحتهم من اللون الابيض الى اللون
الازرق
[موسيقى]
الى هنا تنتهي نشره اخبار الساعه نذكر
بابرز العناوين
وثائقون المسربه تفيد بوجود قوات فرنسيه
وامريكيه وبريطانيه في اوكرانيا والجيش
الفرنسي ينفي
[موسيقى]
من ان حكومته ستدمر اسرائيل ويطالبه بسحب
صلاحيات بن جرير
اسلحه الذكاء الاصطناعي الصينيه تقلق
واشنطن التي تعتبرها تهديدا للهيمنه
الامريكيه
وفوضى مع صعوبه التفريق بين الحسابات
الموثوقه والمدفوعه مشاهير ومؤسسات كبيره
ترفض الدفع
شكرا للمتابعه في امان الله
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات